natalia tomo una muestra aleatoria de 10
países para estudiar la tasa de
fertilidad y la esperanza de vida en la
muestra de datos se percató de una
fuerte relación lineal negativa entre
esas variables aquí tenemos el resultado
de un análisis de regresión de mínimos
cuadrados realizado en computadora para
predecir la esperanza de vida usando la
tasa de fertilidad usa este modelo para
predecir la esperanza de vida de un país
cuya tasa de fertilidad es de 2 bebés
por mujer
puedes redondear tu respuesta de número
de años al entero más cercano pausa en
el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
probablemente necesiten usar calculadora
muy bien resolvamos esto juntos en
general este resultado de computadora en
realidad nos da más información que la
que necesitamos para hacer esta
predicción pero nos da la información
que necesitamos para conocer la ecuación
para una recta de regresión entonces la
forma general de una recta de regresión
una recta de regresión lineal sería
nuestra estimación y ese sombrerito
significa que estamos estimando el valor
que sería igual a la intersección en que
más la pendiente multiplicada por el
valor x ahora en esta situación estamos
usando la fertilidad para predecir la
esperanza de vida lo que estamos
tratando de predecir es que la esperanza
de vida y la fertilidad es lo que
estamos usando para predecir la entonces
va a ser nuestra x justo aquí ahora que
son ahí ve bueno nuestro resultado de
computadora nos lo da son estos números
que tenemos aquí nuestro coeficiente
constante que tenemos aquí esa
y nuestra pendiente va a ser igual a
menos 5.97 podrías verlo como el
coeficiente en la fertilidad recuerden
que esto que tenemos aquí es la
fertilidad incluso podrías describirlo
como nuestra esperanza de vida estimada
podrías ponerle un sombrero para indicar
que es la esperanza de vida estimada va
a ser igual a 89 puntos 70 menos 5.97
multiplicado por la fertilidad por la
tasa de fertilidad le llamaré
simplemente fert fíjense que este es el
coeficiente de fertilidad y este es el
coeficiente constante que podemos ver
acá ahora podemos usar esto para estimar
la esperanza de vida de un país cuya
tasa de fertilidad es de 2 bebés por
mujer para la fertilidad ponemos un 2
aquí y luego obtenemos nuestra esperanza
de vida estimada a que va a ser igual
esto podemos usar la calculadora decimos
5.97 por 2 es igual a esto y lo vamos a
restar así que lo ponemos en negativo y
le sumamos 89.7
es igual y queremos redondear el número
de años al entero más cercano que son
aproximadamente 78 años y terminamos y
para tener claro lo que pasó aquí
natalia hizo una regresión con la
fertilidad en el eje x y el eje
llamémosle v este es nuestro eje y tomó
10 datos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 puso una
recta de regresión intento ajustar una
recta de regresión vio una relación
lineal negativa y luego uso esta recta
de regresión para encontrar si la
fertilidad es digamos que esto es 2 cuál
es la esperanza de vida estimada y
acabamos de ver que eso sería
aproximadamente 78 años hasta el próximo
vídeo